Stephanie how did you guys come together
and what was your impression of this
fine young filmmaker actually met Justin
through Jonathan King participant and
called me up and he knows I I love young
people I love the new ideas coming out
and he said you really should read this
young writer Justin Simien and I did and
how many years ago was that God it was
six six seven or seven years ago and it
was great we had a great conversation we
talked it wasn't anything I really
wanted to pursue but there was
definitely talent there and then the
funny thing about this whole like this
is such a full circle moment is I had
the script called two percent which is
about the two percent black population
on a college campus that would
eventually become dear white people but
it wasn't good enough to like send to
Stephanie late so I sent her something
else but it you know it was the meet I
kicked myself so hard for not having
this ready because this was more like
what you were looking for and I told my
needed something that had something to
say and then hit hard yeah it was
youthful and I was like oh my god it's
perfect except that's not in any way
shape or form finished and then full
circle my daughter saw the trailer that
was up on YouTube and she's biracial and
she was like oh my goodness you have got
to see this and I did we all loved it
and then my assistant told me that
Justin has script and that I should
definitely read it and I did and and
that was that what did you love about it
what was in his script at least what was
it that was unique or appealing to you
about his point of view it was
completely fresh he was saying things
that no one was really saying out loud
it was bodacious it was smart it was
political it was social it was the kind
of movie that you read and you think oh
my goodness we're gonna save the planet
you know there's some young people
coming up that are grappling with issues
and that was very special was it always
inevitable that it had to be satire
could you have made this film if it was
any other genre would it sound different
I think you could but for whatever
reason that's just sort of how it
appeared on the page it was always kind
of comical
so it was always gonna be funny or you
know funny issue it was always going to
be comedic I'll say but then Justin kind
of developing the script it was it was a
real decision it's like with satire I
can actually say something it can
actually have a bite to it it can make
you laugh but also leave you feeling
uncomfortable and and that can be okay
because that's what great satires do and
and also for me it always had to be
multi protagonist it always had to be
coming I always I always had to be
talking about this thing of identity
itself from multiple points of views and
there were perhaps a lot more when i
first started was a lot more you know
ambitious sewer you know the reality
sorted to set it so did Sam and Lionel
and cocoa and Troy kind of push forward
I mean yet you said you were kind of an
ensemble did they speak loudly or more
loudly than the other characters and why
did it kind of start gravitating to them
they spoke they spoke loudly
particularly salmon Lionel who I kind of
see as the anchors of the narrative you
know Sam for me really pushes us into
the second act and Lionel kind of brings
us on home and the third and Troy and
cocoa or you know kind of populate the
middle a bit and there were other
characters but those four for me just
created this nice balance of point
counterpoint you know Coco and Sam from
New York are flip sides of the same coin
and so were Troy and Lionel and that
just there was an economy to that I felt
really nice can you talk a little bit
about how social media played a role in
actually creating part of the story and
I think some of the dialogue in the film
yeah you know once I once I decided that
Sam has this radio show because I
thought she would have a very kind of
you know vintage platform with which to
you know sort of deliver her message in
my head she had this radio show you know
I was toying with the idea of it being
dear white people but I just I didn't I
had nothing like when I came home you
know from my nine-to-five I just I had
enough I'd no jokes I had nothing for
her to say and so you know what I
started doing was tweeting from an
account called at dear white people and
back then people you know you didn't see
the actual persons name so if you bought
a little egg there yeah if you well if
you bothered to go into the profile you
would see that it was by this person
named Samantha white and I just sort of
tweeted about events you know in the
media I tweeted to certain celebrity
I thanked white people from a hawthorn
you know I sort of just like tested out
all of these jokes and the ones with the
most retweets are frankly the ones that
we used in the film the ones that we got
some flack about also were in the film
including the criticism that it provoked
what was that was our specific line or
well you know why isn't there a deer
black people was sort of you know the
main one that I thought was interesting
and the blacker than thou stuff you know
bougie black propaganda a lot of that
language came from frankly people
tweeting at dear white people and so I
yeah it was through this thing I was
able to develop material basically
throughout the days and weeks when I
wasn't able to you know write properly
do you think about it as a movie about
identity or a movie about race or are
they kind of the two sides of the same
coin I think of it as a movie about
identity and particularly the
relationship between identity and self
and you know the ways in which the self
can be short-changed you know to benefit
the identity and vice versa and I'm
talking about that with that certainly a
black lens and therefore racism is in
the world of the story and race politics
are on the mind of the characters and
gender politics are on the mind of the
characters but at the end of the day
they're all struggling with the same
conflicts and a lot of conflict is is a
lot about how mass culture responds to a
person right because of the way they
look and how that person looks at him or
herself because really look yeah i mean
off the time i mean as a person of color
a person of any sort of marginalized
community i think that life in America's
is constantly bobbing and weaving the
cultures perception of you and because
of the energy that that takes I mean
there's already an identity kind of
tailor made for you that in some ways
there's nothing to do with you just
depending on what room that you walk
into and I wanted to talk about the
weight of that and how difficult that
can beat and to navigate especially as
you're trying to form your own identity
let alone figure out who you really are
which is of course the ultimate goal but
yeah I wanted to say something about
that and then what's interesting is
because of the impact that a culture can
have on a person we often feed back to
that culture in the way that it expects
us to and I wanted to get into that too
what kind of resistance are interested
you find in the town itself when you and
stuff and they started talking about how
you get this movie made I mean I think
the the funny thing is is that most
everyone that saw it really responded to
it positively some of them second-guess
themselves and certainly you know when
the script hit the business affairs
departments you know they were they were
really second-guessing it just because
there was no comp for it in the last 20
or so years you know this stuff hadn't
really been dealt with in a satirical
way you know really in several you know
decade or more so so the resistance
really was more about will anyone show
up for the movie and and who's the
audience for the movie and you know what
black people show for a smart satire and
what white people show up for something
called dear white people and there was
all of this this hemming and hawing
about you know well if this isn't
nothing like this made money in the last
two years so how do we know it'll make
money this time I hope you saved those
emails and you could send them your box
office gross this weekend it's so grand
the fact that you are one of the best
reviewed films of the year thank you
Stephanie what else you want to add
something that I suck no I mean I big I
think he's right everybody thought it
was really cool really smart really
fresh but they had no idea how to how to
sell it or sell it within their
organizations how the actors experience
shaped the film itself and how did you
find these actors and what did you think
they brought to the film that maybe you
weren't expecting the film to say well
we have we had a really great casting
director Kim Coleman who did an amazing
job out here in the in Los Angeles and
you know i love i love the Quincy Jones
quote where he says you just got to
leave the door open to like God in the
room I was very familiar with the
characters already and and as a writer
and director I was very aware that like
I could get to in my head about who they
were and I didn't want cardboard cutouts
I wanted archetypes that we sort of sort
of become human beings as a narrative
goes along so I was looking for people
who could not only give me what I wrote
but completely surprised me as well and
and that's really what I was looking for
and you know when tight like when Tyler
came in and he did the scene that we had
seen a million times read beautifully by
fantastic actors and he made me laugh in
the scene and I had never laughed in
that scene before
and I didn't lie it wasn't lat I didn't
intend it to even be comedic you know
that's when I knew he was a kid and
there was a moment like that for each of
them where they just completely brought
like an element of humanity into the
room that was not there before and and
they just breathe light so much life
into where I was like who wrote this so
good he must be good yeah and that as
you're going through the film editorial
a do you find yourself pushing more to
the comedy or pulling that a little bit
back in other words the movie kind of
take on a life of its own that was a
little bit different from the way you
thought it would play the way you
thought people don't have I mean you
know the editing process you just mourn
the movie you thought you made for like
the first few weeks just like okay that
did not turn out as I expected all right
does not play good to know and so you
know for me it was really just about it
was a balancing act because you know
it's it's it's a it's a sprawling script
it's a multi protagonist story and there
were you know different parts of it that
we didn't exactly get to shoot at all or
execute in the way that it was written
in the script so you sort of it then
becomes about just making sure that the
story is balance is sort of making up
for the things we didn't get and and and
sort of like you know really using the
set that was a pleasant surprise and and
that's really what we tried to do we
brought in some audiences to watch
different cuts of it and we just kind of
talked it was incredibly fast i mean
this movie had two weeks of prep and and
because we were trying to make sundance
there was really a few guys came home it
wasn't cut two weeks later we're like
okay you shot in the fall of last year
that's right yeah that's unbelievable i
made your october deadline at sundance
that's razy yeah well it's crazy that
you're here at the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences such a great
film just gonna say Mia and Stephanie
Elaine thank you so much for coming in
thank you guys